دعونا نحضر قناة سي إن إن وليس بشير، فهي
تنضم إلينا على الهواء مباشرة من لندن. من الواضح أن
هناك الكثير مما يجب أن نحزمه هنا، والسبب في أن هذا
جدير بالملاحظة بالطبع هو أننا
اعتقدنا أن بروجسيان كان منفيًا في
بيلاروسيا ولم يُشاهد أو
يسمع عنه منذ وقوع المسلحين  تمرد في
23 يونيو،
ماذا تتعلم ماذا
تسمع، أنت على حق تمامًا، كانت هناك
أسئلة حول
مكان وجوده ولم تتم رؤيته منذ
فشل التمرد قبل أقل من أسبوعين بقليل،
ويُعتقد أنه انتقل إلى
بيلاروسيا  جزء من صفقة تم إبرامها مع
الرئيس البيلاروسي ألكسندر
لوكاشينكو ولكن بالطبع كما
علمنا للتو في الساعة الماضية أو نحو ذلك
وفقًا ليكاشينكا الذي تحدث في مؤتمر صحفي
في مينسك، فإن تقدم إيفجيني
ليس في الواقع في بيلاروسيا ولكن يُقال أنه موجود
في  يأتي هذا الآن في سانت بطرسبرغ في روسيا
حيث نشرت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية
لقطات فيديو يُزعم أنها
لسكان سانت بطرسبرغ تظهر مداهمة للشرطة تم فيها
العثور على أوشحة من جوازات السفر الذهبية بالإضافة إلى أسلحة في هذا السكن
الذي سمعه مقدمو البرامج في هذا الفيديو الذي
يصف هذا  على أنها فضيحة ولكن كما
لاحظت هناك، من المهم أن نتذكر
أن الخبراء والمدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان على
حدٍ سواء غالبًا ما يشيرون إلى حقيقة أن
ما يعادله لديه تاريخ طويل، وهو
نمط من تلفيق القضايا الجنائية
ضد منافسي الجمهور
وبالطبع التقدم المتزايد قد حدث الآن
لبعض الوقت كان منتقدًا صريحًا
لنهج الكرملين عندما يتعلق الأمر
بغزو روسيا لأوكرانيا، وقد
رأينا مرارًا وتكرارًا باغوسيان
يطلق لقطات فيديو يُزعم
أنه يظهر فيها على خط المواجهة، وأحيانًا
مقاطع فيديو مصورة تُظهر ما يصفه
بجثث الروس
المقاتلون المدعومين ينتقدون الكرملين والرئيس
بوتين لفشلهم في تقديم
الدعم الكافي وتجهيز
المقاتلين المدعومين من روسيا على الأرض
الآن في الماضي، قام هذا المنزل بتأمين هؤلاء
المقاتلين بشحنات أسلحة إضافية
لذلك التمرد الذي فشل
التمرد الشهر الماضي وفقًا
للرئيس بوتين.  رئيس فاغنر
ومقاتليه وكلماته عن طريق
الخيانة في ذلك الوقت كان هناك اتفاق
سيتم إسقاط التهم وفقا للكرملين إذا انضم هؤلاء المقاتلون إذا
انضم براغوسيان إلى وزارة الدفاع الروسية
وأجنحة إنفاذ القانون الأخرى
إذا عادوا إلى ديارهم أو  بشكل حاسم إذا
انتقلوا إلى بيلاروسيا كجزء من تلك الصفقة ولكن
الآن بالطبع نتعلم من
لوكاشينكو أنه لا
يقال إن براغوسان موجود في سانت بطرسبرغ وليس في
بيلاروسيا فحسب، بل قيل له أيضًا لشبكة CNN خلال
ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي أنه
يُعتقد أن مقاتلي فاغنر  لا يزالون
متمركزين في معسكراتهم العادية
بالطبع إذا كان البورجوسي موجودًا بالفعل في
بيلاروسيا كما هو آسف في سانت
بطرسبرغ، كما لم يقل لوكاشينكو في
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي، يبقى أن
نرى نوع التداعيات التي
سيواجهها على يد  الكرملين
ليس فقط لانتقاده الصريح ولكن
بالطبع بسبب هذا الفيديو الذي تم
نشره لمداهمة الشرطة لمقر إقامته
في الخارج